[Musica]
mi presento sono io mi chiamo sofia o 13
anni e sto per finire la scuola media
sono autistica quindi l'aspetto che per
primo si nota in me e la profonda
differenza tra ciò che manifesta
all'esterno e quello che sono invece
all'interno fuori sono goffa perché non
struttura bene i movimenti nello spazio
parlo poco e spesso in modo confuso o
atteggiamenti e modi di fare e
riconducibili a quelli di un bambino
piccolo
dentro però ho un universo intero che
non riesce ad esprimersi se non quando
vengo facilitata al computer
il mio sistema neurologico funziona in
modo atipico e così pure la mia mente
sono in grado di registrare e ricordare
un'immensa quantità di informazioni e
questo se da un lato mi permette di
conseguire ottimi risultati a scuola
dall'altro è molto pesante perché un
processo che non posso governare il mio
cervello registra tutto sempre e in ogni
momento
e per questo che o disturbi del sonno
perché di notte continua ad elaborare
rielaborare quello che registro di
giorno per fortuna a differenza di altri
autistici non sono né per uditiva nei
per tattile riesco quindi a tollerare i
rumori forti e non ho problemi ad essere
toccata
sono molto affettuosa il contatto fisico
mi piace e mi tranquillizza come tutti
anch'io ho il mio carattere
paradossalmente data la mia sindrome
sono estroversa mi piace scherzare mi
piace stare con gli altri nelle
situazioni sociali quando il mio livello
d'ansia me lo permette riesco a gestirmi
bene posso stare in pizzeria con i miei
amici
posso andare al cinema senza troppi
problemi riesco a comportarmi bene
quando sono a casa d'altri in un negozio
o in un ufficio sono particolarmente
tenace nel provare
e riprovare ad imparare tutte quelle
abilità che la sindrome autistica
compromette come parlare usare il denaro
gestire i miei stati d'animo e cercare
di essere autonoma il più possibile
nella mia vita quotidiana sono anche
perfezionista vorrei fare tutto bene e
mi arrabbio molto quando non riesco il
mondo delle mie emozioni e ricco ma
anche molto difficile da governare il
livello della mia ansia può aumentare in
modo così repentino da sfociare in vere
e proprie crisi tutti i miei sforzi in
questa direzione sono volte di imparare
a come evitare di arrivare al punto di
non ritorno
perché una volta oltrepassato posso solo
aspettare che la crisi passi sono anche
molto sensibili allo stato d'animo di
chi mi è vicino e delle persone che
incontro intuisco facilmente carattere
punti di forza e debolezze
sono curiosa di tutto praticamente mi
piacciono tutte le materie che studio
anche se prediligo la lettura e
soprattutto amo molto scrivere
faccio tutto il possibile per migliorare
sempre per non arrendermi e per
riprovare ogni volta ecco questa sono io
non mi merito indifferenza non mi lascio
medicare il cuore non mi merito mille no
non voglio essere molto divina non
nomino mai il mio tenero di vino modo di
essere
mi mostro sempre per come sono mi butto
miracolosamente in situazioni grottesche
mi metto in gioco per farmi notare
mi merito millesi non mi merito
indifferenza mi gioco il mio dono
migliore il mio sorriso mi mostro mentre
butta via il mio orgoglio non mi
lasciare nell'indifferenza non mi dire
che non mi prendi sul serio non mi
governare come se fosse un illusione mi
finisco di mentire
mi dico che non è vero non indifferenza
ma solo noi
ciononostante mi vorrei migliorare molto
le mie parole in poesia mi fanno volare
se io fossi il presidente del consiglio
se io fossi il capo del consiglio fatto
in impeto uno sbadiglio mi vedrei molto
sincera non smentì ray da mattina a sera
farei tante cose per il paese e non solo
per un solo marchese tutti mi
riferirebbero inginocchiandosi davanti a
me e io risponderei invitandoli per un
te ti dico che sarei veramente
democratica e umana non mi gratteri il
culo per tutta la settimana
ti dico che sarei impegnata e
disponibile non direi cose inverosimili
e pagherei l'imponibile
lanterne cinesi oltre non vedo nulla
solo gradazioni di colori colpiscono
tamburellano fluttuano deserto di luce
si concentra in forme enormi grondano
letteralmente vivide lanterne bere luce
io vorrei non mi danno tregua piccola io
mi sento lo spazio mi fa sentire precari
a persona
ho dato il mio destino al cielo ne ha
fatto luce di luce
tremo di gioia nel vedere molteplici
getti brillanti fortunata sento in me
razzi di mille sfumature ho mollato la
ragione per seguire l'anima giro intorno
a me stessa non mi trovo più
ho sognato amore ho fatto un sogno ho
visto un mondo gioioso molto felice in
cui tutti formano immensi timorosi
turbini d'amore
ho visto un mondo in cui nomi
diversamente uguali si incontrano e si
parlano anche se non usano la stessa
lingua
non mi voglio illudere non mi voglio io
illudere vorrei ma mi guardo intorno e
vedo lamentosi esseri dimostrare la loro
faccia peggiore
vorrei ma mi vedo davanti la gnosi
uomini fare di tutto per seminare odio
vorrei ma vedo volti stupefatti
indignati ma incapaci di reagire
mi unisco ai pochi che vogliono tentare
fino allo sfinimento perché un giorno
tutti si destino ad ansie e paure perché
un giorno dovremmo un giorno diremo un
giorno rivivremo un giorno finiremo di
farci portare via da idee violente e da
omuncoli finti uomini duri uomo e chi sa
fiutare amore anche dove sembra che non
si possa più trovare
favola breve povero pesce un giorno un
pesce decide durante una gita di andare
a trovare un amico mentre nuota felice
incontra un suo fratello più povero che
ne chiede in prestito un grappolo di
cibo al gusto pizza promettendogli di
restituire il tutto al più presto passa
parecchio tempo
il pesce ha voglia del suo grappolo
chiama il fratello ma questo non
risponde pesce è molto arrabbiato e
continua a cercare il fratello
finalmente lo trova ma non ria proprio
il suo grappolo morale non sempre ci si
può fidare degli altri lampi di vita
come mi fai molto tornare indietro nel
tempo mi dici nomi già sentiti molti
dimenticato di conoscerli
ho un mio duro carattere mostrato solo a
chi se lo merita
vorrei fare il mio salto nel buio
vorrei staccarmi dal nido vorrei
mostrare nobili intenti con e stimata
notorietà mi faccio conoscere
io dopo di loro non vorrei mai molti
giri di parole per dire che io non
vorrei gioire se non ci sono loro forse
mi basterebbe con molto tatto unire la
mia anima a loro nell'immensità del mio
destino
vedo mille molteplici lampi di vita
[Applauso]